بفارق ضئيل جدا انتزع جمهوريون الغرفه
الاولى الادنى من الكونجرس مجلس النواب
لتكون مفاصل الحكم في واشنطن منقسمه لكن
ما الذي يعني ايه انقسام الحكومه في
واشنطن وكيف سيؤثر هذا على الرئيس جوبايدن
خلال العامين المتبقيين من عمر ادارهته من
المرجح ان يكون ماذا نفود الجمهوريين
محدودا بسبب اداءهم في الانتخابات المصريه
والذي لم ياتي بموجه حمراء كما كان متوقعا
سيطره جمهوريين ضيقه على مجلس النواب
يتوقع ان تعرق النسبيا فرصه اي تشريع
رئيسي لبايدا سيكون الرئيس ديمقراطي مضطرا
للتعامل مع قياده معارضه له في مجلس
النواب في الجمهوريون قالوا انهم يخططون
للضغط عليه لخفض الانفاق الحكوميه واجراء
تغييرات سياسيه اخرى من خلال التهديد بحسب
الاموال المخصصه لابقاء تمويل الحكومه
مستمرا
اضافه لذلك يقول القاده الجمهوريون ان
خططهم تشمل تعزيز امن الحدود وتقييد
الاجهاض والتشجيع المزيد من الاجور
لعناصير الشرطه وهو ما يخالف تماما سياسات
بيدن وسياسات الديمقراطيه ايضا سيكون
الرئيس في موضع الدفاع عندما يستخدم
الكونجرس سلطته الرقبيه للتحقيق مع
الاداره وعائله الرئيس خاصه لجهه نجله
هانتربويدين الذي قال الجمهوريون ان
تحقيقا بشانه بدا بالفعل كما قد تشمل
تحقيقات الجمهوريين المجمعه ايضا موضوع
الهجره من الحدود الجنوبيه مع المكسيك
وفوضى الانسحاب من افغانستان هذا على
الصعيد الداخلي اما خارجيا فربما ينفذ
الجمهوريون التهديداتهم بشان اوكرانيا
نذكره هنا ان رئيس مجلس النواب المرتقب
كهف المقارتي قال انه لا ينبغي ان تمنح
اوكرانيا شكا على بياض في مساله مساعدات
العسكريه لكن امام الجمهوريين مهمه شاقه
للدفع اجندهم يبدا اول فصولها بتوحيد
الاجنده المختلفه داخل الحزب وايضا لم
يتاخر في قراءه هذا الوضع الشائك على فكره
فقد اكد ان الناخبين لا يريدون نزاعا
سياسيا مستمرا وانه يخطط لدعوه قاده الكلى
الحزبين الى البيت الابيض في الاسابيع
المقبله
[موسيقى]